[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal Solidarität
Solidarität mit Israel in Berlin rund
2000 Menschen kamen heute zu einer
Kundgebung am Brandenburger Tor um ihr
Mitgefühl zu zeigen und ihr Entsetzen
über den Terror der
Hamas guten Abend zum heute journal
Israel meldet inzwischen über 700
Todesopfer eine erschütternde Zahl erst
recht für so ein kleines Land und der
Terror geht ja noch weiter mehr als 100
Menschen werden als Geiseln gehalten wir
werden uns der Lage in Israel in dieser
Sendung noch sehr ausführlich widmen
blicken jetzt zunächst aber erstmal auf
die Landtagswahlen in Deutschland
Bayern und Hessen sind
bevölkerungsreiche Bundesländer die
Wahlen dort betreffen mehr als 20
Millionen Bürger die Ergebnisse sind
auch für die Bundespolitik
relevant kurz gesagt haben die Wahlen
zwei Sieger hervorgebracht einen
überglücklichen Ministerpräsidenten
Rhein in Hessen und die AFD die größten
Verlierer sind SPD und FDP die
desaströse Ergebnisse erzielten in
Bayern kann Amtsinhaber Söder ebenfalls
weiter regieren aber wirklich zufrieden
kann die CSU nicht sein matthias fornof
hat in unserem Wahlstudio in München die
aktuellen Zahlen und wir fangen mit
Bayern auch an Matthias so machen wir
das die neueste Hochrechnung für Bayern
sehen wir hier 22:08 Uhr demnach kommt
die CSU auf
36,6% verliert etwas die Grünen 14,9 mit
Verlusten die Freien Wähler 15,1
gewinnen dazu die AFD 15 ,9 wäre damit
zweit stärkste Kraft 5,7 Punkte die SPD
7,9 verliert noch mal die FDP 2,9% nicht
mehr drin 6,7 für die kleineren Parteien
zusammen was heißt das für die
Zusammensetzung des Landtages nach
sitzen 205 Sitze gibt es 83 für die CSU
34 für die Grünen 34 ebenfalls für die
Freien Wähler 36 für die AFD und 18 für
die SPD wer kann mit diesen
Regierung bilden wir schauen das mal an
CSU und Freie Wähler die die letzten 5
Jahre miteinander regiert haben 117
Sitze die kommen relativ locker über die
103 die man für die absolute Mehrheit
braucht das gleiche gilt für CSU und
Grüne 117 klar drüber CSU und SPD 101 da
fehlen zwei Sitze das sind erstmal die
Fakten und Zahlen für Bayern danke schön
Matthias ja ein historisch schlechtes
Ergebnis für die
CSU da sind wir ein historisch
schlechtes Ergebnis ist das für die CSU
und darüber habe ich vor einer halben
Stunde mit Markus Söder gesprochen zuvor
aber stimmen und Stimmungen aus Bayern
die Simon Pfanzelt für uns
zusammengestellt
hat Markus Söders Auftritt als Sieger
erzählt nur die halbe Geschichte er hat
seine CSU heute zwar wieder zur
stärksten Partei gemacht allerdings mit
dem schlechtesten Ergebnis seit 73
Jahren Sieg und
ganz n beieinander mein eindeutiges
unklares versprechen Bayern bleibt
Bayern auch wenn die Welt langsam
verrückt wird darauf kann man sich
verlassen herzliches Danke schön alles
Gute es ist ein Wahlabend der Fragen
hinterlässt etwa die ob die Demokratie
nun eigentlich gewonnen oder verloren
hat die AFD wie im Rausch
Oppositionsführer in den nächsten Jahren
danach sieht es aus rechtsen freentumel
ohne unsere Basis sind wir nichts aber
mit unserer Basis sind wir alles und wir
holt diesem Land unsere bewte Demokratie
zurück liebe
Freunde fast ein Drittel der Wähler in
Bayern hat heute rechts von der CSU
gewählt auch Hubert eiwangers Freie
Wähler legen zu und dürften in einer
neuen Koalition mit der CSU mehr Macht
fordern das ist ein Traumergebnis für
uns jetzt schauen wir natürlich wie die
Zahlen dann endgültig aussehen und dann
beginnen wir zu rechnen und zu
verhandeln aber wir sind hoch
aufzfrieden heute ist
freiewähler auch die Grünen geben sich
heute als Sieger trotz leichter Verluste
stehen sie von allen ampelparteien am
besten da weil Söder mit ihnen nicht
koalieren will stellen sie sich auf fünf
weitere Jahre in der Opposition ein der
Rechtsrutsch muss ein wegruf für alle
DemokratInnen und Demokraten hier in
Bayern sein wir Grüne sind die
verfassungsschützerin und
Verfassungsschützer wir werben daür die
diese Demokratie zu stärken zu schützen
denn sie ist das Beste was wir haben für
die SPD bleibt Bayern schwieriges
Terrain wieder einstellig und noch
einmal schwächer als vor 5 Jahren es ist
offensichtlich dass wir es nicht
geschafft haben unsere landespolitischen
Themen für ein bezahlbares Bayern auf
die Straße genügend auf die Straße zu
bringen ist alles überlagert worden von
der schwierigen Gesamtlage in der wir
sind die Bayern Strafen die Ampel ab am
härtesten trifft es die FDP verpassen
die Liberalen den wiereinzug in den
Landtag außer parlamentarische
Opposition mal
wieder es ist uns nicht gelungen ihnen
zu vermitteln warum es gerade jetzt eine
liberale weltoffene
fortschrittsorientierte Partei im
Bayerischen Landtag braucht es ist uns
als bayerische FDP auch nicht gelungen
uns von einem bundespolitischen negativ
Negativtrend abzukoppeln Bayern hat
gewählt die alte Regierung wird woh die
neue sein doch der Ton im Landtag dürfte
rauer
werden und der bayerische
Ministerpräsident ist uns aus München
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr Söder
schön guten Abend grüß Gott das ist ein
Ergebnis mit dem man z Ministerpräsident
bleibt aber das kann man sich eigentlich
nicht schön reden oder ja es ist ein
stabiler Regierungsauftrag nach
turbulenten Wochen anders kann man es
nicht sehen wir hatten ja in diesem
wkampf Herausforderung dies es noch nie
zuvor gegeben hat auf der einen Seite
eine normwachsene AFD wie wir es auch in
Hessen leider jetzt gesehen haben und
umgekehrt eine sogenannte flugplatffähre
die tatsächlich viel durcheinander
gewirbelt hat und wir haben durch ein
volminanten schlussspur so würde ich das
sehen am Ende noch ein sehr stabiles
regierungsergebnis erzielt ein
Regierungsauftrag für die CSU und für
mich auch ganz persönlich insofern
können wir auch kraftvorgieren na ja vor
vier Wochen haben sie im heute journal
gesagt und da gab's die flugblatffäre
schon und auch die AFD war kein neues
Phänomen dass ein Ergebnis so in der
Nähe der 40% belastbar wäre Zitat jetzt
sind aber unter 37 das ist jetzt
eigentlich nicht wirklich bel lastbar
oder wie schätzen Sie das ein na ja die
40% wurden immer von anderen genannt ich
habe nie eine einzige Prozentzahl
genannt ich habe immer gesagt wir wollen
ein starkes und stabiles Ergebnis haben
und ein klaren Regierungsauftrag zu
haben den haben wir dann am Ende auch
wie ich finde doch sehr gut erzielt und
noch einmal die sie sehen ja wie die
Demokratie durcheinander gewirbelt wird
dass Parteien rausfallen ganz schwach
werden die früher ganz fest zum
politischen demokratischen Establishment
gehört haben zeigt es verändert sich was
in der Demokratie in Deutschland da sind
wir klar die stärkste Kraft die
deragegen hält die die Demokratie
zusammenhält aber in der Tat es stimmt
auch wir müssen uns noch den Folgen
mitnmen die Folgen heißen für mich und
ist das Wichtigste überhaupt dass diesem
Wahlergebnis die nationale Aufgabe die
Migrationspolitik zu einer Wende zu
führen zu einer einem Pakt gegen
unkontrollierte zubandung das glaube ich
ist der eigentliche Auftrag den wir aus
den beiden Landtagswahlen am Ende ziehen
können sie haben diesen Wahlkampfjahr
eigentlich als eine Art
oppositionswahlkampf geführt immer
wieder gegen die Ampel vor allen Ding
gegen die Grünen undun hat der parallel
ebenfalls wahlkämpf der unionskollege
Boris rin einen ganz anderen Wahlkampf
gemacht und ist damit aber eigentlich
erfolgreicher er hat Stimmen dazu
gewonnen macht sie das nicht
nachdenklich der die Situation zwischen
Hessen und Bayern ist eine ganz andere
weil wir hier die Konstellation mit den
Freien Wählern haben die nach dieser
sogenannten flugblatffäre ja den
Umfragen ja fast durch die Decke
geschossen ist die Umfragen die damals
zeitweis waren die waren da bei 17 plus%
da hat sich das doch jetzt wieder auf
ein anderes Maß dann eingepegelt und vor
den Umfragen vor dieser flugplatfähre
lagen wir deutlich höher also man kann
es nicht ganz vergleichen für uns war
immer nur ganz klar ein schwarzgünes
Regierungsbündnis hätte für Bayern keine
Option bedeutet dabei bleibe ich das war
ja ein Fehler gewesen die Grünen haben
in Berlin nicht den Nachweis der
Regierungsfähigkeit erbracht und haben
auch in Bayern eine völlig andere
unterschiedliche Auffassung wie Bayern
sich in der Zukunft gestalten soll und
wir haben fünf jah gut gemeinsam regiert
und wollen es jetzt auch fortsetzen sind
aber die Grünen in Hessen nicht völlig
andere als die grünenen Bayern das hat
jetzt nicht auf zwei verschiedenen
Planeten stattgefunden diese Wahl und
dort zeigen sie sich ja offenkundig auch
Regierungs fähig nun haben sie selbst
gesagt ein rund ein Drittel der Wähler
hat heute AFD oder Freie Wähler gewählt
da würde sich Franz Josef Straus doch
eigentlich im Grabe umdrehen und die CSU
hatte immer diese Herausforderung auch
zu Zeiten von Straus da gab's
Bayernpartei die damals anders da war da
gab's Republikaner da gab's auch dann
eine NPD mal die im harten Kampf war
diese Herausforderung gibt es und gab es
immer und die AFD ist mittlerweile ja
nicht nur eine deutsche Herausforderung
sondern sie ist ja im europäischen
Umfeld mit entsprechenden
partnerparteien genauso da also wir
wegen uns da schon in einer europäischen
Realität die ich nicht gut finde und es
wird auch die große und zentrale Aufgabe
sein dagegen anzugehen und ich
persönlich würde sagen bin auch ein
schutzgarant ich bin ein schutzgarant
Gen ein weiteres Anwachsen der AFD und
auch ein schutzgarant für Minderheiten
unserem Land damit Sie sich darauf
verlassen können dass sie hier frei und
gut leben können Herr Söder danke ihn
für das Gespräch sehr gerne wie gesagt
wirklich freuen kann sich hingegen der
hässische Ministerpräsident Boris rin
ist der erst seiti letzten Jahres im Amt
und hat aus dem Stand für die CDU-Wähler
zurückgeholt und ein wesentlich besseres
Ergebnis erzielt als sein Amtsvorgänger
bei der letzten Landtagswahl vor 5
Jahren dann schauen wir wieder auf
unsere aktuellen Zahlen im Wahlstudio
Matthias wir sehen die neuesten Zahlen
für Hessen aus ja maretta die meisten
Stimmbezirke in Hessen sind ausgezählt
und daraus ergibt sich die folgende neue
Hochrechnung 22:17 Uhr die CDU
34,5% mit deutlichen Zuge
holt vieles zurück was sie vor 5 Jahren
verloren hat die Grünen 14,8% deutliche
Verluste die SPD 15,1 demnach sogar kurz
vor den Grünen noch ebenfalls Verluste
die AFD zweitstärkste Kraft 18,4%
deutliche Gewinne die FDP bei 5% könnte
es noch schaffen in den Wiesbadener
Landtag die Linke nicht mit 3,1% und
auch nicht die Freien Wähler mit 3,5%
die anderen zusammen die kleineren 5,6%.
jetzt schauen wir wir mal auf die
Sitzverteilung in Wiesbaden im Landtag
132 Sitze gibt es 52 für die CDU 22 für
die Grünen 23 für die SPD 28 für die AFD
und wenn es den reicht für die FDP
werden das noch mal 7 wer kann mit
diesen Zahlen mit wem regieren das
schauen wir uns an die absolute Mehrheit
die liegt bei 67 sitzen das sehen wir
hier schon die amtierende Koalition
schwarzgrün kommt deutlich drüber 74
sitze das gleiche gilt für CDU und SPD
die kommen sogar auf 75 sitze und
könnten regieren SPD Grüne und FDP wenn
die denn drin wäre würde es trotzdem für
dieses Dreierbündnis deutlich nicht
reichen danke schön Matthias mit den
aktuellen Zahlen mit Boris rin habe ich
eben auch über das Wahlergebnis
gesprochen und welche Schlüsse er daraus
zieht gerade mit Blick auf die
politischen Strategien der Union aber
auch hier erstmal der Bericht vom
Wahlabend da war Susanna Santin für uns
in Hessen
unterwegs er ist ohne Zweifel der große
Wahlsieger in Hessen Boris rin hat nicht
nur seine erste Feuerprobe bestanden es
war seine erste Wahl sondern auch alle
Umfragen übertroffen deutlich über
30% liebe Freunde dieser
10 wird in die Geschichte hessenunion
eingehen und eines ist ganz klar die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Hessen haben
gewählt und sie haben einen klaren
Regierungsauftrag erteilt und zwar an
die CDU Hessen die CDU Hessen hat den
klaren Regierungsauftrag der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger weit hinter einer strahlenden
CDU hat es für die SPD noch nicht einmal
für Platz 2 gereicht Spitzenkandidatin
nen sie Feser fährt ein historisch
niedriges Ergebnis ein ihre Asylpolitik
als bundesinnenministerin beschert dir
immer wieder Kritik mit landesthemen kam
sie nicht durch für uns ist klar und das
will ich auch in aller Deutlichkeit
sagen das Wahlergebnis ist sehr
enttäuschend was auch sonst
wir haben uns erhofft in diesem
Wahlkampf dass wir eine Landesregierung
anführen können wir hatten viel
Gegenwind wir haben es in den Umfragen
gesehen deswegen ist es auch nicht ganz
überraschend aber trotzdem sehr
enttäuschend die Enttäuschung stand an
diesem Abend auch Tarik alvasier ins
Gesicht geschrieben der hässische
Wirtschaftsminister hatte stets versucht
sich von den quirelen der Ampel im Bund
abzugrenzen gelungen ist es ihm am Ende
nicht wir hätten uns natürlich ein
besseres Ergebnis gewünscht aber wenn
ihr euch diese Hochrechnung jetzt
anschaut dann ist das einfach so alle
Parteien die an der Bundesregierung
beteiligt sind hatten keinen Rückenwind
und wir mussten Berg
aufkämpfend ein Rekordergebnis erzielt
dagegen die AFD Spitzenkandidat Robert
lambru macht im Wahlkampf vor allem die
Migrationspolitik zum Thema sprach von
der Masseneinwanderung die seine Partei
beenden werde er fühlt sich
bestätigt das ist das mit Abstand beste
Wahlergebnis für die in Westdeutschland
jemals es wäre ein enormer
Vertrauensvorschuss von ganz vielen
Bürgern die erstmals AFD gewählt haben
und es ist wichtig dass wir dieses
Vertrauen auch erfüllen in den nächsten
5 Jahren spannend bleibt es bei der FDP
sie zittert noch um den Einzug in den
Landtag wir machen es manchmal spannend
in Hessen und es ist auch heute Abend
wieder so we ich denke es wird gelingen
keine Chance mehr hat die Linke nach 15
Jahren ist sie in Wiesbaden nicht mehr
dabei ist sie nach 15 jah deswegen ist
es natürlich total bitter aber klar ist
auch dass die Themen bleiben werden der
Kampf für soziale Gerechtigkeit gegen
den Rechtsruck die bleiben wichtiger
denn je am Abend trafen sich dann noch
die derzeitigen Koalitionspartner ob es
bei schwarzgrün auch in den nächsten 5
Jahren bleibt kann Boris rin
entscheiden und der Ministerpräsident
von Hessen ist uns zugeschaltet guten
Abend her
rein ja guten Abend Frau Slomka sie
strahlen schon den ganzen Abend und
jetzt auch auch noch natürlich auch aus
guten Gründen da muss man natürlich
sofort Fragen haben sie sich jetzt in
den illustren Kreis der potenziellen CDU
Kanzlerkandidaten auch hochgewählt
sozusagen ah also also das ist jetzt für
mich überhaupt gar kein Thema
ich habe wirklich einen Auftrag erhalten
eine Regierung zu bilden und dann dieses
Land zu führen und dafür bin ich
wirklich muss ich sagen unheimlich
dankbar den Wählerinnen und Wählern aber
natürlich auch unseren Wahlkämpfer
und das ist jetzt meine Aufgabe ja das
ist klar dass das jetzt natürlich
erstmal ihre Aufgabe ist aber sie wissen
natürlich auch dass man in der Union
heute guckt wie lief das in München wie
lief das in Wiesbaden und es ist schon
auffällig dass sie mit einer ganz
anderen Strategie in diesen Wahlkampf
gegangen sind als die von Markus Söder
auch anders sich äußern als der
Parteivorsitzende Friedrich märz und
damit ja ziemlich viel Erfolg gehabt
haben heute wie erklären sie das ihren
Parteifreunden was sagen sie
dazu na ja unsere Strategie ist
natürlich eine hässische Strategie
gewesen ähm wir marschieren immer
gemeinsam wir leben wirklich Union als
Gemeinsamkeit und
für uns ist es ganz besonders wichtig
dass wir beieinander sind und nicht
gegeneinander sind und das hat sich
offensichtlich ausgezahlt na aber so
ganz beieinander sind sie ja in der
Union nicht also sie und Herr wüst und
Daniel Günther sie haben einen anderen
Kurs als Friedrich märz und und der
Generalsekretär Herr Lindemann das muss
in irgendeiner Form auch ausdiskutiert
werden und Sie haben zumindestens heute
Abend ganz gute Argumente gesammelt denn
Markus Söder konnte sich nicht
verbessern im
Gegenteil ja aber das würde ich so nicht
sehen dass wir
ähm nicht mit äh cararsten Linnemann und
mit Friedrich merzind ganz im Gegenteil
wir arbeiten sehr eng zusammen wir
stimmen uns auch sehr eng mit der
bundescdu ab das gilt für Hendrik wüst
das gilt für Daniel Günther das gilt
auch für mich ähm wir sind schon sehr
beieinander muss man sagen und das gilt
im übrigen auch natürlich für Markus
Söder ich habe das von Anfang an für
sehr wichtig gefunden dass es eine Achse
Wiesbaden München gibt und die leben wir
auch sehr
aktiv trotz aller Achsen die sie aktiv
leben haben sie sich ja trotzdem
wahrscheinlich nicht allzu sehr gefreut
über die letzten Äußerungen die es dann
von Friedrich Merz gaben die für einige
Erregung sorgten bezüglich der
arzttermide die den deutschen angeblich
weggenommen werden von Asylbewerbern das
war das Rückenwind oder war das
Gegenwind
ach ich würde das gar nicht so
ähm ja wie soll ich sagen betonen dass
das Gegenwind gewesen ist ganz im
Gegenteil ich muss Ihnen sagen
Friedrich März hat ja zu einer
Diskussion geführt und das was er gesagt
hat die in der Mitte geführt wird in der
Mitte der Gesellschaft nicht an den
rechten Rändern der Gesellschaft ähm und
so habe ich das auch verstanden und wer
das wie betont wer welchen Sound da
reinbringt das ist halt eben
möglicherweise im mein Unterschied aber
am Ende ist es wichtig dass wir die
Themen in der Mitte der Gesellschaft
diskutieren und das zeigt auch das
Ergebnis der AFD jetzt in Hessen wir
müssen die Themen ansprechen wir müssen
sehr klar formulieren
und das ist glaube ich der Auftrag für
die nächsten Jahre ist aber jetzt in
Hessen auch nicht gelungen damit wenn
Sie das sich selbst so beschreiben die
AFD klein zu halten im
Gegenteil ja das
ist in der Tat so dass das Ergebnis der
AFD uns nicht gefallen kann aber ich
will sehr deutlich sagen der Unterschied
der und der Abstand der Union zu den
anderen auch zur AFD ist so groß und so
stark dass man natürlich ja erkennen
kann dass wir mit unserer Strategie
richtig gewesen sind und richtig gelegen
haben aber insbesondere wir auch
wirklich die Themen angesprochen haben
und
die ich sag mal die Größe der AFD hat
natürlich da damit zu tun dass das Chaos
auf Bundesebene und der Streit der auf
Bundesebene stattfindet eben so ist wie
er ist und deswegen ist das eher ein
Berliner Ergebnis was die AFD betrifft
als ein hässisches Ergebnis was die AFD
betrifft sagt der hässische
Ministerpräsident Herr rein danke ihn
für das
Gespräch ja ich bedanke mich sehr auch
von Boris rin keine Kritik an seinen
Parteivorsitzenden übt wird sich die
Union natürlich Fragen stellen müssen
welchen Kurs sie v folgen will eher den
von Friedrich MZ und Markus Söder oder
eher den von Boris Rin und Henrik wöst
noch mehr Fragen muss sich die Ampel
stellen die Grünen sind aus dem
Wahlabend ja noch insgesamt halbwegs mit
heiler Haut herausgekommen die beiden
anderen ampelpartner in Berlin
Sozialdemokraten und FDP hat es deutlich
schlimmer getroffen im Kanzleramt dürfte
man außerdem nicht glücklich darüber
sein milde gesagt dass mit Nancy fer
auch noch eine bundesinnenministerin der
Art beschädigt aus diesem Wahlabend
herausgeht und dann ist da noch der
Jubel bei der AFD der allen anderen
Parteien Kopfzerbrechen bereiten muss
Patrizia wiedemeierer sortiert für uns
die Stimmungslage in Berlin bei keiner
der drei ampelparteien herrscht heute
Abend wirklich Feierlaune alles dunkel
bei der SPD keine Wahlparty nur ein
kurzes Interview Erklärungsversuch der
Vorsitzenden die
migrations Thematik ist ein komplexes
Thema und dort wden werden eben die
einfachen Antworten gewählt das sind die
Rechtspopulisten die die zu bieten haben
das sind keine Antworten das sind nur
scheinantworten sie hätte Antworten
geben müssen in Ministerin nenny fer
doch nach dem debarkel für die SPD in
Hessen fraglich ob sie so geschwächt
weiter Ministerin in Berlin bleiben kann
Rückendeckung bekam sie zumindest heute
Abend
noch Feser ist erfolgreich und stark im
Kampf gegen Rechtsradikale und ihre
Vereinigung in unserer Gesellschaft und
an dieser Zwischenbilanz ihrer Amtszeit
nach kaum zi Jahren hat sich mit dem
heutigen Abend nichts geändert sie hat
unseren klaren Rückhalt als
bundesinnenministerin auch bei der FDP
keine Feierlaune ein kurz angebundener
Generalsekretär morgen in allen grämien
werde man die Ergebnisse bewerten und
wir werden aber auch innerhalb der
Koalition diese Ergebnisse analysieren
und besprechen vielen Dank irgendwie
stabil fest verankert obwohl auch sie
verloren haben sich die Grünen und
appellieren an die Koalitionspartner
sollten wir vielleicht mal davon
wegkommen Politik immer als ein Spiel
des gewinnen und Verlierens und wer hat
sich am Ende durchgesetzt son wir müssen
es gemeinsam als Ampel hinbekommen
Lösung für die Probleme der Menschen im
Land zu gewinnen Jubel dagegen bei der
CDU vor allem der hohe Wahlsieg in
Hessen könnte ein klares Signal in der
kanzlerkandidatenfrage sein Boris Rhein
gewann indem er nicht polarisierte sich
von der bundescdu und dem Vorsitzenden
März absetzte
hat sensationellen Wahlkampf gemacht
fehlerfrei klare themenfokussierung und
die CDU Hessen war geschlossen genauso
muss es sein Jubel natürlich auch bei
der AFD sie ist zweitstärkste Partei in
beiden Ländern Meinungsforschern zufolge
ein Ergebnis der schlechten ampelpolitik
Ergebnisse setzen sich natürlich
zusammen vor allen Dingen unsers dass
wir über die Jahre immer mehr Menschen
von unserer freiheitlichen Politik
überzeugen konnten es ist ein
erüchterndes Zeugnis für die Ampel zur
Hälfte der Legislaturperiode der
spdvorsitzende kündigt Konsequenzen an
das nehmen wir sehr ernst und da muss
jetzt mehr Tempo und auch ein anderer
Stil rein mehr Tempo beim Thema
Migration das dürfte schwierig werden
mit den Grünen und das Regieren mit der
FDP die nach Niederlagen ja in der Regel
eine härtere gangheit einlegt sowieso
keine guten
Aussichten zu den Wahlen in Bayern und
Hessen jetzt ein Kommentar von der
Chefredakteurin des ZDF Bettina
Schausten an einem Tag wie diesem an dem
die Zeichen in N Ost auf Eskalation
stehen ein weiterer Krieg unserer
Aufmerksamkeit und die volle Solidarität
mit Israel fordert scheinen
Landtagswahlen in deutschen Landen
ziemlich nachrangig und was ist denn
schon passiert zwei Ministerpräsidenten
der Union werden wiedergewählt samt
ihrer Koalitionen in Hessen wird der
CDU-Mann Boris Rhein gestärkt in Bayern
kommt Markus Söder mit einem blauen Auge
davon beide können mit ihren Partnern
weiterreieren also ein gediegenes weiter
so hinterd weiter so ist allerdings
einiges passiert am heutigen Wahltag das
braucht Beachtung und vor allem
Konsequenzen Lektion 1 mit Ansage war
dies ein debakkel für die ampelregierung
in Berlin alle Parteien geradezu
abgestraft Verluste am brutalsten für
die SPD Spitzenkandidatin in Hessen die
als
bundesinnenministerin die Ampel gerade
zu verkörper te im Wahlkampf und die
Versäumnisse der Regierung beim
Hauptthema Migration nun müssten Tempo
und Stil der Ampel verändert werden
fordert der spdchef und das ist vor
allem ein Appell an den spdkanzler Olaf
Scholz Lektion 2 die AFD ist kein
ostdeutsches Problem Deutschland
insgesamt rückt an diesem Abend nach
rechts Rekordwerte in Hessen und in
Bayern und dafür ist nicht nur
Schlechtes Regierungshandeln
verantwortlich auch die CDU und ihr
Vorsitzender müssen sich fragen welches
Angebot Sie unzufriedenen Wählern machen
und damit folgt Lektionen die Lehre
Spaltung hat Deutschland nun wirklich
genug und Verunsicherung wenn sich der
Trend nach rechts außen bei der nächsten
der Europawahl im Juni nicht verstärken
soll braucht es jetzt das Zusammengehen
von Ampel und Unionsparteien den breiten
demokratischen Schulterschluss ob er nun
deutschlandpakt heißt oder anders in
einer gemeinsam Erklärung haben CDU CSU
SPD Grüne und FDP sich heute solidarisch
erklärt mit Israel als Partner und
Freund das war ein wichtiges und starkes
Signal und auch eines das die
Perspektive zurecht drückt angesichts
der Schrecken die andere erleiden in
diesen Tagen und Stunden sind unsere
Probleme klein und gemeinsam
lösbar Bettina Schausten kommentierte
und damit schließen wir die
Berichterstattung über die
Landtagswahlen ab ab und kommen zu dem
anderen großen und bitteren Thema dieses
Tages der Terror gegen Israel und der
Krieg der daraus folgt und der über
lange Zeit die ganze Region beherrschen
und gefährliche Weiterungen nehmen kann
dass die USA am Abend verkündeten dass
sie einen ihrer Flugzeugträger und
weitere Kriegsschiffe ins östliche
Mittelmeer verlegen spricht Bänd
Bundeskanzler Scholz warnt vor einem
Flächenbrand der weil die Menschen in
Israel weiter unter Schock stehen und
das Land weiter angegriffen wird
Christiane Hoffmann fasst die Lage
zusammen Trümmer in einem Krankenhaus in
askelon im Süden Israels eine Rakete der
Hamas hat hier Zerstörung
gebracht wir versuchen einen Überblick
über die Schäden zu bekommen das war ein
sehr sehr schwieriger Tag und eine noch
schwierigere
Nacht am Tag danach zeugen auch inot nah
der Grenze zu Gaza einer Polizeistation
vom Überfall der radikalislamischen
Hamas auf Israel die israelische Armee
hatte sich gestern den ganzen Tag Kämpfe
mit der terrormiliz geliefert in
Trümmern auch die Überzeugung von der
Unbesiegbarkeit und der Sicherheit der
Israelis wo ist die Armee die Regierung
wo sind all die Sicherheitsfaktoren die
das israelische Volk an jedem Ort
schützen müssen angesichts dessen was
hier in Israel
geschieht Israel noch immer vereinzelt
Kämpfe die Soldaten gehen von Ort zu Ort
noch immer werden hamaskämpfer in Israel
vermutet der Angriff hat seit gestern
700 Israelis das Leben gekostet mehr als
2000 wurden verletzt rund 100 Kinder
Frauen und Männer wurden
verschleppt die israelischen
Verteidigungskräfte haben die Kontrolle
an den durchbruchstellen an der Grenze
von Gaza zu Israel wiederhergestellt die
Armee hat hunderte Terroristen
getötet Ministerpräsident Netanyahus
Sicherheitskabinett erklärte formal den
Kriegszustand was ein größeres
militärisches Vorgehen ermöglicht viele
Beobachter schließen eine Bodenoffensive
in Gaza nicht aus den Armeeeinheiten
werden Richtung Gaza verlegt und
Reservisten eingezogen schon vergangene
Nacht hatte Israel damit begonnen
hamasstellungen in Gaza zu zerstören
auch hier Trümmer und Leid nach
palästinensischen Angaben starben 400
Menschen mehr als 2000 wurden
verletzt im Norden verstärkte Israel
seine Grenze zum Libanon denn dort hatte
die von Iran unterstützte islamistenmiz
Hisbollah israelische Posten auf den
Golanhöhen beschossen international
wächst die Sorge vor einer
Eskalation die Ereignisse in nost
Strahlen weltweit aus auch nach Berlin
in der Nacht demonstrierte eine
proalästinensische Gruppe und tagsüber
bekundeten rund 2000 Menschen vor dem
Brandenburger Tor ihre Unterstützung für
Israel Bundeskanzler scholz sagte israel
habe das Recht sich zu verteidigen wir
verurteilen das Vorgehen der Hamas auf
das
Schärfste vor allem aber setzen wir
alles daran dass aus diesem Überfall
kein Flächenbrand mit unkalkulierbaren
Folgen für die ganze Region wird und wir
warnen alle davor in dieser Lage den
Terror zu befeuern und
weiterzutragen die Bundesregierung will
nun die Finanzhilfen für die
Palästinenser auf den Prüfstand stellen
und gleichzeitig auch helfen eine
Deeskalation in nost zu
vermitteln dann schalten wir live nach
Israel nach Tel Aviv zu unserem
Korrespondenten Michael beberunge
Michael welche Informationen liegen dir
vor wie es jetzt am Abend die Lage in
Israel also das ganz unmittelbare
Problem hat die Armee offenbar noch
nicht lesen können nämlich die
Sicherheit in die Kontrolle über die
Dörfer und Gemeinden in unmittelbarer
Nähe zum Gazastreifen wiederherzustellen
davon konnten wir uns heute selber
überzeugen wir waren für einige Stunden
in sterot was noch nicht offiziell von
der Armee wieder freigegeben worden ist
ist gleicht einer Geisterstadt die
Menschen haben sich immer noch in ihren
Häusern verstandst Soldaten durch kämen
die Stadten wir wurden unmittelbar
während eines
Interviews was wir führten Zeuge eines
plötzlich entstehenden feuergefechts äh
darüber hinaus scheint der Aufmarsch für
die mögliche Bodenoffensive begonnen zu
haben wir konnten Panzerkolonnen im
raumsterot beobachten die ihre
aufmarschräume eingenommen haben und die
Armeeführung hat mehrere hunderttaus
Reservisten einberufen ausdrücklich mit
dem Hinweis auf eine mögliche
Bodenoffensive und ausdrücklich mit dem
Hinweis dass Israel auch in der Lage sei
einen mer frontenkrieg zu stemmen ja das
wäre die nächste Frage es gab ja auch
schießereienattacken von der hisbolla im
Norden vom Libanon aus wie wird das in
Israel eingeschätzt ist das so
einzuschätzen dass die Hizbollah jetzt
auch in diesen Krieg
einsteigt momentan glaube ich das noch
nicht ich würde es eher als einen
symbolischen Akt der Unterstützung der
Kämpfer in Gaza bewerten aber natürlich
könnte die libanesische hzbollah äh
versucht sein bei einer Bodenoffensive
in Gaza Israel ebenfalls in einen
Zweifrontenkrieg mit der Front im Norden
zu treiben aber die Gefahr BGT natürlich
auch für Sie für die hzbollah dass
andere Nationen hineingezogen werden
Syrien die USA und auch der Iran und
gerade der Iran dürfte momentan an einer
solchen Eskalation kein Interesse haben
kan man nur hoffen Michael Bunger
erstmal vielen Dank nach Tel
Aviv
wie die Terroristen der Hamas mit ihren
Geiseln umgehen darunter viele Frauen
und Kinder das spottet jeder
Beschreibung es ist ein Grauen und es
ist ein Grauen für Israels Regierung
entscheiden zu müssen wie erpressbar sie
sich zeigen wird man mag sich nicht
ausmalen was da noch alles auf die
Israelis zukommt mehr als 100 Menschen
sind nach israelischen Angaben in den
Gazastreifen verschleppt worden ihr
Schicksal ist ungewiss es gibt
Filmaufnahmen von von Verschleppungen
von verängstigten Kindern die vorgeführt
und misshandelt werden es gibt auch das
Entsetzliche Video wie die Terroristen
den nackten Körper einer Geisel auf
ihrem Pickup schenden eine junge Frau
die vermutlich deutsche Staatsbürgerin
ist kameran safiarian berichtet über die
entführten sie tanzen fröhlich und
ausgelassen zu Elektromusik junge
Menschen am frühen Samstag Morgen auf
einem Musikfestival nah dem kibutz RE im
Süden Israels osion am Himmel panik
bricht aus bewaffnete hamasterroristen
überfallen das Musikfestival töten 260
Menschen nehmen Geisel darunter die
25jährige Studentin noahamani aus Israel
und ihren Freund wo no sich derzeit
aufhält ob sie noch lebt ist nicht
bekannt ihr Vater völlig
verzweifelt ich habe geseh gib einem
Motorrad nach Gaza entführt worden
sein ich habe gehofft es wäre ein Irrtum
aber es war Noah total
verängstigt ich habe sie doch immer so
beschützt doch jetzt konnte ich sie
nicht
[Musik]
beschützen auch die deutschisraelin
Shani Luk wurde auf dem Musikfestival
entführt die 22-Jährige stammt aus
Ravensburg ihre Familie ist vor langer
Zeit nach Israel ausgewandert die
Terroristen posieren mit ihrem reglosen
Körper auf einem Pickup in Gaza sie
bespucken und schlagen Sie shanys Mutter
wendet sich an die
Öffentlichkeit man hat uns ein Video
zugeschickt wo ich eindeutig unsere
Tochter erkennen konnte bewusstlos im
Auto mit den Palästinensern und wie sie
den Gazastreifen abgefahren sind ich
bitte jede Hilfe oder jede
Neuigkeiten bitte zu uns schicken vielen
Dank pure Angst auch bei J aser seine
eine deutsche Frau Doron war mit den
beiden Töchtern zu Besuch bei der
Großmutter nah dem gaserstreifen sie
telefonieren am Samstag gegen 10 Uhr
während die Terroristen bereits im Haus
sind dann reist der Kontakt ab aser
entdeckt seine Frau und Kinder dann auf
Videos im Netz in den Händen der Hamas
Terroristen ich weiß nicht wo meine Frau
ist was mit meinen beiden Töchtern
passiert sie sind doch noch Babys die
eine nicht einmal drei die andere 5
Jahre alt ich habe Angst ihnen etwas
zustößt vielleicht werden sie
unangemessen
behandelt die Ungewissheit ist kaum
auszuhalten hier an einer Infostelle am
Flughafen buon suchen Menschen nach
Informationen über ihre vermissten oder
entführten Angehörigen mehr als 100
Menschen sollen laut israelischen
Angaben von der Hamas als Geiseln
gehalten werden darunter laut
Auswärtigem Amt auch einige deutsche ihr
Leben ist in höchster
Gefahr
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit Michael
rot dem Vorsitzenden des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses im Bundestag er vertritt
dort die SPD die Kanzlerpartei guten
Abend Herr rot guten Abend Frau slomke
das ist schwer erträglich das anzusehen
egal welcher Nationalität die Geiseln
sind und soll es auch einige deutsche
darunter geben haben Sie irgendwelche
Informationen aus dem Krisenstab des
Auswärtigen Amtes
dazu das sind herzzerreißende Bilder fr
Slomka haben darüber heute Abend auch
mit der Außenministerin gesprochen wir
müssen jetzt um jeden kämpfen wir dürfen
niemals vergessen das was gestern
stattfand in Israel war das größte
Massensterben von jüdenin und Juden seit
dem Holocaust und daraus muss ich auch
unser Handeln ableiten und unsere
Solidarität in Deutschland die mehr sein
muss als ein Lippenbekenntnis was kann
es denn mehr sein als
Solidaritätsbekundungen ganz ganz
konkret also dazu gehört erst einmal
dass wir jetzt Israel versichern wir
unterstützen euch dabei dass ihr euer
Land sichert und wieder
befriedet und es bleibt den israelischen
Freundinen und Freunden keine andere
Wahl sie müssen jetzt die Infrastruktur
der Hamas ein für alle Mal vernichten
der Gazastreifen den Israel seit 2005
verlassen hat ist mehr oder weniger ein
terrorlager Israel ist von Feinden
umgeben die dieses Land zerstören wollen
die die Menschen vernichten wollen und
das muss uns auch in Deutschland klar
werden weil wir immer wieder dazu neigen
und sagen na ja es ist ganz furchtbar
aber eigentlich sind die Israelis ja
selber dran schuld und das stimmt
einfach nicht ja dann kann ja insofern
heute eigentlich nur froh sein dass es
auch diese Kundgebung am Brandenburger
Tor pro israel gab und nicht nur aus
Deutschland Bilder aus Neuköln kam und
ist das was dort zu sehen war jubelnde
Sympathiebekundungen für die Hamas
aber ja nicht nur ein paar vereinzelte
sie haben es ja selber gesagt es ist
schon auch tiefer verbreitet in der
deutschen Bevölkerung und auch in
zugewanderter Bevölkerung sehr kritisch
über Israel zu sprechen und zu denken
also erst einmal bin ich sehr sehr
dankbar dass CDU CSU SPD Grüne und FDP
heute ein gemeinsames eine gemeinsame
Erklärung abgegeben haben um deutlich zu
machen wir in Deutschland die politisch
Verantwortlichen stehen an der Seite
Israels ich bin aber heute auch im Zug
unterwegs gewesen von meiner Heimatstadt
Bad herersfeld nach Berlin um unter
anderem auch zu Ihnen zu kommen und da
habe ich vieles gehört ja man ist
entsetzt aber eigentlich tragen die
Israelis ja auch eine Mitverantwortung
und wir Deutsche müssen
uns dieser wir müssen uns dieser
Realität stellen es gibt Länder es gibt
Terrororganisationen es gibt Kräfte die
sich in der unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft
Israels befinden die wirklich wollen
dass Israel von der Landkarte
verschwindet und das sind eben nicht nur
Terrororganisationen wie der Hamas oder
auch hiszbollah das ist vor allem auch
Iran sollte man gegenüber Iran dann noch
mal eine andere Gangart überlegen ich
meine die EU überlegt schon seit
Ewigkeiten ob sie die iranischen
Revolutionsgarden den wirklich
terroristenparten sind auf eine
Terrorliste setzt aber da kann scheint
man ja nicht so richtig zu Potte zu
kommen
die Europäische Union hat sich in den
vergangenen Jahren außerordentlich
schwer getan weil sie natürlich auch
versucht hat Iran davon abzuhalten eine
eigene Atomwaffe zu entwickeln dennoch
muss jetzt klar sein der Iran ist kein
verlässlicher Verhandlungspartner und es
liegt auf der Hand dass das was jetzt
geschehen ist an furchtbaren an
grauenhaften in Israel nicht alleine von
der Hamas organisiert wurde sondern dass
es dafür auch eine iranische
Unterstützung gegeben hat andere Frage
die jetzt diskutiert wird ist wie man
mit den palätin den Geldern für die
Palästinenser umgeht da gab's letzte den
letzten Jahren eine ganze Menge also ich
glaube in den letzten zwei Jahren
zusammen irgendwas um die 340 Millionen
allein an deutschen Steuergeldern die in
Palästinenser Gebiete gingen dafür gab
es ja auch ein Grund man wollte es jetzt
nicht nur arabischen Staaten überlassen
da als Geldgeber aufzutreten aber muss
das jetzt nicht noch mal ja neu überlegt
und gegebenenfalls auch beendet
werden das Ereignis ist so einschneidend
dass wir alles auf dem Prüfstand stellen
müssen und ich bin auch unserer
entwicklungsministerin dankbar dass sie
das so deutlich zum Ausdruck gebracht
hat wir leisten natürlich auch in einem
großen Umfang humanitäre Hilfe es gibt
kein Staatsgeld aus deutschen Kassen an
die palästinensischen autonomiebehörden
auch nicht an diesen schrecklichen Herrn
Abbas der es ja noch nicht mal fertig
gebracht hat sich von den
Terroraktivitäten der Hamas zu
distanzieren es ist humanitäre Hilfe die
vor allem der Gesundheitsversorgung
dient Wasser sauberes Wasser aber wenn
es um
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit geht da bin
ich ganz bei Ihnen müssen wir in der
Europäischen Union und müssen wir in
Deutschland alles überprüfen es darf
nicht mal im entferntesten der Eindruck
entstehen dass wir wirklich
indirekt Terrororganisation wie Hamas
unterstützen sagt der Vorsitzende des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses danke ihn Herr
rot ich danke
ihnen angesichts dieser Schrecken in
Nahen Osten liegt aktuell etwas weniger
Augenmerk darauf dass es in Afghanistan
eine große
Erdbebenkatastrophe gibt und damit
beginnen jetzt bei dir die Nachrichten
Heinz ja inzwischen meldet der
Katastrophenschutz des Landes eine stark
gestiegene Zahl von Todesopfern mehr als
2000 Menschen kamen demnach im
Erdbebengebiet ums Leben tausende seien
verletzt worden und es wird befürchtet
dass die Opferzahlen noch weiter steigen
gestern Morgen hatte eine Serie von
Beben mit einer Stärke von bis zu 6,3
die Region
erschüttert
russland hat in der Nacht erneut mehrere
ukrainische Regionen angegriffen im
Gebiet saporisia wurden laut
Behördenangaben zwei Menschen durch
russischen Beschuss getötet in herson
seien zudem elf Menschen bei Angriffen
auf ein Wohngebiet verletzt
worden in Spanien haben erneut
10tausende gegen eine mögliche Amnestie
für Vertreter der katalanischen
Unabhängigkeitsbewegung protestiert sie
werfen Ministerpräsident Sanchez vor
eine solchen Straferlass in Aussicht zu
stellen um die Unterstützung von
unabhängigkeitsbefürwortern für eine
weitere Amtszeit zu bekommen
Oppositionsführer fecho sprach von der
Kund vor der Kundgebung in Barcelona von
einem
Machtmissbrauch zum Sport an diesem
Sonntag zuerst zur Fußball buundesliga
heute mit drei Spielen Leverkusen hat
3:0 gegen Köln gewonnen und Bayern
München ebenso mit 3:0 gegen den SC
Freiburg und in der abendpartie
Frankfurt gegen idenheim ging Frankfurt
als Sieger vom Platz mit 2:0 an der
Tabellenspitze steht Leverkusen vor
Stuttgart und
Bayern bei der turnweltmeisterschaft in
Antwerpen hat Lukas Dauser Gold am baren
gewonnen superübung das war perfekt
sagte Bundestrainer belenki zu dausers
Leistung er ist der erste deutsche
Turner mit WM Gold seit Fabian Hambüchen
vor 16
Jahren und die deutschen Volleyballer
haben sich erstmals seit 2012 wieder für
die Olympischen Spiele qualifiziert die
Mannschaft setzte sich beim
Qualifikationsturnier in Rio de Janeiro
durch sie hat nach einem 3:0 gegen Qatar
vorzeitig die Olympiateilnahme in Paris
im kommenden Jahr erreicht und vor Qatar
hatte das Team bereits gegen die
Favoriten aus Brasilien und Italien
gewonnen jetzt noch die Wetteraussichten
morgen regnet es im Norden und Osten
zeitweise im Südwesten scheint öfter die
Sonne und es bleibt trocken die
Temperatur erreicht nicht an der hafel
nur 12 am oberrein sommerliche
28° und es bleibt im Norden deutlich
kühler als im Süden wo bis zu 28°
erreicht werden oft ist es freundlich
der Meister regenfällt am Mittwoch ganz
im Norden am Donnerstag in der
Mitte das war's im heutejournal an
diesem Sonntagabend weiter geht's gleich
mit Musik und einer feierlichen
Preisverleihung im Konzerthaus Berlin
ausgezeichnet werden vielversprechende
Nachwuchskünstler und bekannte
Musikstars mit dem Opus classic das ist
ja der nachfolgepreis des echolassic und
danach gegen 045 gibt es die nächste
heute Express und hier erwarten Sie
morgen Christian Siebers und Hanna
Zimmermann auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
wiedersehen